et vous êtes donc en direct avec nous
bonsoir merci ce qui ne passe toujours
pas aujourd'hui c'est notamment
l'article 24 de la proposition de loi
sécurité globale qui pénalise la
diffusion un malveillantes d'image des
forces de l'ordre pour le gouvernement
la mesure vise à protéger les policiers
victimes d'appel à la haine et au
meurtre sur les réseaux sociaux
alors le rassemblement national a voté
en faveur du texte à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que cet article 24 vous
semble nécessaire pour protéger les
policiers
oui complètement parce que les policiers
sont souvent hélas mise à mal sur les
réseaux sociaux avec des appels à la
haine contre eux ou contre leurs
familles et par rapport à ça c'est
importante et protégés
lorsqu'on voit que les policiers font
très bien leur travail il y en ait fait
de temps en temps mais comme dans toutes
les professions des écueils et des
choses qui sont très dommageables c'est
évident mais on a besoin de cet article
pour protéger en effet les policiers
mais lorsque je regarde un petit peu
même les manifestations et les images
qui sont diffusées
ce que je regrette surtout c'est cette
prépondérance cas le gouvernement a
cristallisé les tensions et à faire
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas uniquement
cette manifestation pour la loi sécurité
mais s'est également plaint de personnes
qui manifestent parce que il n'y a pas
de réponse qui a pas de gouvernement
courir on a les opposants à la loi
estime que cet article 24 empêcherait de
filmer les forces de l'ordre
d'intervention en pêche français de
documenter les violences policières quel
est votre regard là-dessus il ya en
effet lorsqu'il ya des violences
policières de toute manière après
derrière il ya une enquête
et lorsqu'à une enquête les personnes
sont incriminés et sont jugés il faillit
faut aussi penser à toutes ces familles
de policiers qui sont mises à mal et
leurs enfants dans les écoles
le problème c'est qu'il ya toujours des
dommages collatéraux donc quand l'aide
quand il ya des interpellations qui sont
musclés qui ne doivent pas se faire
c'est évident qu'elles doivent être
réprimandés à leur juste valeur
mais à côté de ça ou ils ont droit aussi
une protection ils ont un métier
regarder un petit peu les images qui ne
sont pas évident non plus il se retrouve
très souvent face à des personnes qui ne
sont pas des enfants de coeur donc
protéger ces personnes c'est aussi dans
le c'est dans l'intérêt
on a besoin de la police faut remercier
les forces de l'ordre et faut aussi être
reconnaissant par rapport à leur travail
donc oui nous sommes pour cet article 24
et non pour sa suppression alors pointé
du doigt également par les
protestataires usage des caméras piétons
et des drones par les forces de l'anp
est ce qui vous semble en effet faire au
rassemblement national les caméras
piétons et les drones est prêt il ne
faut pas quand tu entres dans une dérive
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas rentrer dans
un état totalitaire on ne peut pas se
mettre comme si nous étions en chine
dans d'autres régimes de ce type mais on
est quand même aussi dans un pays si
vous par là on peut plus se promener
bien évidemment mais si on vend
voyageant où on est quand même avec
beaucoup de sécurité et choses qu'on ne
retrouve pas dans tous les autres pays
donc qu'on ait besoin de mettre en place
ce système de protection pour assurer la
protection des concitoyens
ça me semble être une bonne chose mais
il faut en effet faire attention à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de dérive non plus et
alors qu'en face on trouve le juste
équilibre
comment est ce qu'on trouve le juste
équilibre entre eux
surveillance de la délinquance notamment
et maintient du droit d'informer le
droit de manifester le droit alors le
droit de manifester je l'entends mais
regardez il ya quelques années quand on
voit les manifestations les gens
défilaient avec leur pancarte maintenant
des manifestations il me restait quoi il
reste la saveur de manifestation avec
des black blocs qui vont infiltrer les
trous avec des milices d'extrême gauche
qui mériterait quand même d'être
dissoute et finalement l'appel et le
centre des manifestations de leur sens
plus alors après par rapport au fait
comment trouver un juste équilibre mais
déjà mettons en place on verra
et en effet si on arrive sur une dérive
totalitaire vous savez les lois elles
sont faites aussi pour que d'autres lois
mais un ménage celles qui sont en place
mais manifestation aussi aujourd'hui
pour défendre la culture quelles
seraient les propositions du
rassemblement national pour ne pas
ouvrir et les acteurs du monde de la
culture justement déjà lors les noms de
la culture et que ce monde complètement
oublié pourquoi parce que nous sommes
encore dans toujours d entre eux de
confinement on s'approche certainement
vers un troisième confinement mais
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement prend
des mesures incohérentes
marine le pen avait proposé depuis un an
de fermer les frontières chose que
beaucoup d'autres pays ont fait et qui
s'en sortent beaucoup mieux au niveau
des virus on n'a pas écouté cette
proposition pourquoi uniquement parce
qu'elles émanent du rassemblement
national et qui a cette volonté de dire
non tout ce qui touche aux assemblées
nationales nous ne voterons pas où nous
n'appliquerons pas mais le monde de la
culture se retrouvent aussi sinistré
parce que on est dans une
dans ce schéma depuis un an en france où
le virus
on n'arrive pas du tout l on peut pas
dire l'endiguer parce que personne ne
peut l'en dit gay mais où on n'arrive
pas à le canaliser un peu mieux on voit
encore le problème qu'on a avec les
vaccins les vaccins maintenant on ne
peut pas être dotée des dotations qui
sont promises toutes les teintes
cafouillage depuis le départ et le monde
de la culture est pénalisée par rapport
aux mauvaises décisions prises par le
gouvernement depuis un an pour revenir
sur les manifestations de ce samedi
toujours dont contre la proposition de
loi sécurité globale les discussions du
beauvau de la sécurité ont démarré est
ce que
ça vous semble aller dans le bon sens
pour notamment retrouver ce juste
équilibre entre les forces de l'ordre et
la population un lien qu'on dit être
mise à mal et ce grâce à votre
ressentiment aussi non alors pour moi
tout ça c'est de la communication
on est quand même dans un système qui
est bicaméral on va voir d'un côté le
sénat d'un côté l'assemblée nationale et
c'est là devront se décider et céladon
s'écrire cette loi ce projet doit donc
tout ce qui est beau tout ce qui est
pareil on avait on lui parle également
qu'on allait prendre une trentaine de
citoyens pour parler de la campagne de
vaccination tout ça c'est de la
communication
c'est comme lorsque emmanuel macro
faisait le tour de france en demandant
aux personnes ce qui n'allait pas final
c'est de la com il ne se passera rien il
ne se passera rien ni boule à moi je
n'attends rien du tout du bobo ni comme
toutes les autres petits groupes
qu'emmanuel macro et son gouvernement
mettent en place
parce que dans notre vème république il
y a le sénat et à l'assemblée nationale
le reste c'est que de la communication
et sur le schéma de l'anc un cadre qui
fait aussi partie des discussions
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez qu'elle a égalé votre regard
qu'elle est solide du rassemblement
national le maintien de l'ordre ce que
je disais en préambule
moi je suis je suis mais outré quand
j'entends les élus notamment de la
france est soumise qui tire entre
guillemets à boulet rouge sur les forces
de l'ordre en disant les mauvais les
méchants policiers mais qu'elle sera un
état sans forces de l'ordre surtout
quand on voit la criminalité qui sévit
dans notre pays il faut il faut que les
élus sortent sur le terrain et qui vont
un peu ce qui s'y passe les cambriolages
les agressions
cc c'est pas c'est pas eric tout ça
c'est ce qui passe passe dans la réalité
alors certains aussi met en avant
peut-être un problème de recrutement de
formation des policiers
pour vous il n'y a pas de sujet 6 il
peut y avoir un deux sujets là dessus en
effet qui est des améliorations en fait
quant au recrutement
quant au fait de la formation ça je
pense que c'en est fait quelque chose de
très bien mettre en place mais ne
rompent pas incriminer c'est ce que je
vous disais tout talent peut pas
incriminer tout un segment professionnel
par rapport à quelques problèmes qu'il
se passe
combien à des interpellations combien il
ya de
si réel dans 99% des cas cela se passe
bien et encore une fois les policiers ne
sont quand même pas nous n'ont pas
affaire à des enfants de choeur on
envoie plusieurs des vidéos également
sur les réseaux sociaux où ils se font
tirer dessus ou autres par des
projectiles je vais vous dire moi même
s'il se retrouvait dans une
manifestation alors non pas le genre est
parti je me suis retrouvée entre les
policiers et les gilet jaune était le
deuxième week-end il ya deux ans de ça
eh bien j'ai honnêtement la peur de ma
vie puisque j'étais entre les projectif
des hommes ils lancent sur les mici des
pavés ils sont aidés par et des
poubelles
il ya quand même une il faut arrêter de
minimiser ce que les forces de l'ordre
subissent merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france allen laporte députée
européenne du rassemblement national